[Musique]
et toi
désolé pour le verre le verre d'oreille
si c'est pour la journée vous allez
chanter cette chansonnette cette thème
musical désolé également parce que c'est
le décès de Louise Dussault cette grande
comédienne Louisette Dussault qui
s'était éteinte à 82 ans hier
paisiblement entouré de ses filles et
donc faut dire que elle a fait le
bonheur des petits de 1964 à
19611 et donc c'est plus de 700 épisodes
700 émissions elle était aimante
rassemblage et aussi c'est particulier
parce que ça c'était pour les petits
mais pour les adultes on avait une
actrice impliquée militante féminine
féministe aussi dans ses choix et tout
ça cette éveil là c'est passé à l'école
de théâtre lorsqu'elle a gradué elle
voulait jouer des textes dans un
français qui lui ressemble et tout de
suite elle s'est retrouvée justement
dans les belles soeurs de Michel
Tremblay alors il y a eu ce pavage de
voilà et là je vais vous parler de les
faits en soi ce fut des créations
marquantes à laquelle elle a participé
en Vierge Marie qui venait déconstruire
les stéréotypes féminins alors ça
brassait Marc-André
[Musique]
de son jeu et là je pense à Maryline
dans les années 90 cette quotidienne à
la télé de Radio-Canada en femme de
ménage et il y avait ce petit rire très
taquin qu'on retrouvait très souvent qui
nous accompagnait autre petit extrait
le client qui aura plus de secret pour
moi
ah mais comme ça vous cherchez une femme
de ménage et bien je suis votre homme
ça me fait sourire je vois ça me fait
vraiment rigoler et on l'a vu dans
Picotine dans chez Denise le parc des
braves chop suey aussi Marc-André et les
héritiers Duval donc vraiment cette
carrière à la télé très très remplie
mais aussi aussi au cinéma où elle a
tenu quoi une vingtaine de rôles dans le
7e art et dire qu'elle avait cette
personnalité forte qui était dans
l'engagement artistique mais dans
l'engagement politique et là était
candidate au parti rhinocéros à la début
des années 70 candidate aux élections
scolaires de co-ansville aussi délégué
pour l'Union des Artistes elle a eu deux
filles dans les années 70 Eve et Paul
qui par ailleurs l'ont accompagné dans
ces derniers instants c'est ce qu'on a
compris hier vous les avez vu ces deux
fils dans watata alors comme quoi elles
ont suivi la trace de leur maman vous
êtes sous décider hier à 92 ans
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI